what are go I need to borrow your car
what I have nine things I need to do
tonight you just get your boyfriend to
do it ex-boyfriend fault in our stars in
Paper Towns what do you think it is
about John Green's writing which makes
it perfect for movies you know I just
think he writes really well drawn
complex characters that um when they're
put into movies they're kind of like an
actor's dream you know and did you watch
robot and frank I did yeah before we
started shooting I loved it I mean Jake
is like he's a he's a mastery and he's
the most in control director I've ever
worked up and his shots are so beautiful
so watching the movie it seems to me
that there are several different love
stories happening there's the guys and
the girls but also the bromance would
you agree yes yeah yeah I mean I think
one of the messages of the movie is that
romantic love is not the only kind of
love that's important or the only kind
of love that can kind of hold you
together and it's really the lovin in
friendships that's that's the most
important and I think the romantic love
story in the movie is really between
jazz and justice is really between angel
and radar and it's a great great love
stories one of my favorite things about
the movie and it's also got great themes
of you know people might be more than
what you think they are what kind of
truths do you think it tells to me
that's why I wanted to be in the movie
my heart was that message is like so
close to my heart just because I really
related to Lacey and how she feels
misunderstood and a lot of times you
know young or older you walk into a room
and you feel like people are judging you
just based on the way look when you
really want them to see you as a more
complicated real person and I think
that's what's so special about John's
characters is he writes these dynamic
teenagers that you don't always find in
the movies and
I don't find Margo it's all for nothing
thank you don't get lost before you find
yourself
you